oh the nighttime air was barely freezing  well it was cold but not quite freezing  [Music]  so i looked  around my trousers  and this voice inside my head grooves  out of pants oh faded pants overrated  pants is overrated yes yes pants is  overrated pants is overrated pants  overrated yes yes yes yes yes yes yes  yes yes well i'd have never made it out  that window  [Music]  circumstance i gladly lost my favorite  pants pants  [Music]  yes  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  my people from across the bone  [Music]  yes  yes yes  yes  yes  yes yes  see the little sheep is big and fat  standing on the hillside standing in the  meadows  lord jesus knew just what to wear  again  [Music]  shoes and sang this knife  [Music]  [Music]  yes  [Music]  children come into this  [Music]  is  [Music]  yes  [Music]  yes yes yes yes  you